[Musik]
ist in die oft wild roh und adoptiert
wurde
40 jahre später ist sie zurück und sucht
die familie
volker kronisch im zweiten weltkrieg aus
deutschland export flüchtet nach 50
jahren wagt zurück die vergangenheit
wir waren nur unglücklich
[Musik]
das ist trug zur wurzel preis im mini
fremd heimat gemeint im kanton zürich
wohnt zwei bands mit pfiff sie ziehen
die vom schweizer adoptiert wurde
hütet sie kontakt mit adaptiver ältere
firma willi hat sich zwei jahre vor dem
markttrend mit ihm zusammen hat sie fünf
jahre gedacht jetzt wird sie endlich die
ursprungsfamilie fühlt und du dir eis
und der strom um und machen jetzt
[Musik]
vielleicht finde ich dabei bin und ich
hatte schritt gewagt
will sagen
[Musik]
seit langem auf der suche nach antwort
auf die frage wo sie zu ihrem leben hat
sich spürt sachen wo sie sich nicole
klarem englisch cc schotte wo sie
begleitet darum gott sie zu eine
botschafterin für die geistige war dass
ich jeden tag habe mich begleitet sollen
und jetzt nicht nur am morgen so genau
wer den ganzen tag und somit auch keine
große finden
wer das jetzt und ich das gefühl es hat
ganz viel medium sie möchte wissen was
sie erwartet und ob sie endlich mehr
über ihre familie sind
[Musik]
ich danke dir
geburtstag damit das genaue geburtsdatum
einfach nicht mehr möchte ich gern und
das hat den wunsch so wie ich möchte
jetzt gerne wissen wo sind meine
verwandten konzentrieren
so haben wir das lenkrad vor den
richtern
das ist natürlich mit ihm einzelne quasi
erkläre aber zwei ist konnte nun ohne
zwang und schufen blocks 2 und das ist
schon was kleeblatt also das heißt wir
hatten glück die hand weg mit dem
projekt das gefällt mir
ich tue mich jetzt einfach online
verbinden und thonet alles einzeln
erklären aber was ist das
das heißt ich sehe was du von meinem
platz beschlossen große fluss hat der
fluss macht erachten kurse und ich sehe
erste flasche
es muss irgendwie muss ästhetik und über
das ist sagen bestätigung es musste
sowie eine fabrik oder usa wo mit
trinkwasser herstellt und riegeln die
sowieso und den usa
also ich glaube einfach dass ihr täter
wieder kümmert wenn ihr den platz ging
aber ich bin sicher als hat verwandte
und ich glaube was ich auch über hunger
ist dass man sie nicht gern gehörtes hat
er wieder aus als erwartet so sechs
spiele ich habe als kind erste 27 sehr
wenige bewachung okay
und nachdenken das team ja ganz genau
unter sich aus
die also dass gott spielen aber groß mit
rassismus ein laster familienverbund de
cix ist also sehr große familie
ja ja und das ok ich spiele auf jeden
fall ist jetzt einfach auf dem papier
sind redaktion
es war schwierig wäre das könnte
schwierig werden
[Musik]
barbara kroll und ihre morde markus sind
unterwegs auf mädchen burg in
norddeutschland am anti vom zweite
weltkrieg ist mit ihrer familie aus
ihrem heimatort kolberg über die ostsee
flüchtet lütjenburg zieht verbraucht
nach dem krieg wo die leute nicht freuen
die leute waren ja völlig nur 200 und es
gab es zu essen
es gab nichts und ich mein es waren ja
auch keine unmenschen sie sahen dass die
flüchtlinge litten aber so setzte brot
teilen das war dann eben doch nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wo nichts los
die 2
ich bin ja kein klären sind über 40 j
für beide ist es die zweite nicht woher
hat markus es jeden tag nach bern
gefahren und ich hab beratungsbüro
gehabt und habe hier gearbeitet
ich frage das konnte allerdings viel
unterwegs nicht aber hier
[Musik]
das war dann schon eine umgewöhnung nach
der pause leo dass jetzt plötzlich den
ganzen tag zusammen waren nicht mag muss
ich noch wie geht's herzlich willkommen
ich mache es nicht zu da nina später mit
john und nina das sind die worte die der
e3 sie die fremde heimat schon seit
wochen es großes thema heute familie
sportbereich sieht ihre flucht niemetz
grobe exil in dem ort wo sie die erste
jahr klappte und wo ihre eltern rust
statt
ich denke immer
[Musik]
im märz 1964 sehr zähes der heimatverein
tag aufeinander müsse verlor sich
zusammen mit ihrer jüngeren schwester
der mutter und verwandten geflüchtet
kronberg hat damals nur zu deutschland
gehört statt wochen krieg chronisch
wurde in diesen tagen vor 50 jahren
brannten servierte schon polnische
truppen die polnische hafenstadt kolberg
sie war mit flüchtlingen überfüllt wenig
mehr als 3000 deutsche soldaten
verteidigten die stadt das ist denn die
stadt nicht das soll die letzte
erinnerung die ich habe viele tage gegen
gewalt letzte erinnerung müsse darin
schrecklich schon lange zu punkt ja es
war schon weg gegangen sagt war einfach
nichts den jahre desto weg dann wisst ja
die hat mir gesagt sie sie konnte die
die stiefel von dem russen hören lesen
eines tages haben wir beschlossen wir
müssen jetzt kommen die russen immer
immer näher
und dann haben wir noch zusammen kaffee
getrunken nachmittags mit kuchen und
dann sind wir zusammen zum hafen und
dann ist ein schiff gekommen und mit dem
hätte man fliegen soll
und dann haben wir gesehen wie ein
schiff explodiert es mit auf der mine
und sie sind alle tot gewesen
und mein vater mein großvater kannte den
den hafenmeister da konnten wir
übernachten und dann sind wir auch
schiff gekommen und da waren auch kein
platz mehr
und dann hat man alle auf dem schiff
daraus dass auch kalt
und dann ist uns allen schlecht geworden
und dann gab es eine will ich kann die
wurde im kreis gesagt und zahlreiche
trotz die wohlhabend familie hat alles
müsse zurücklag sich nun ums überleben
können was ihr mann die flucht über das
meer erwartet damals niemanden sagt
barbara und ihre familie sind
schlussendlich mehr als zwei jahre als
flüchtling deutschland kreist freimuth
in höchst denn sind die pläne dort
lütjenburg gelandet und dann hat sich
die bevölkerung verzehnfacht
ich glaube das hat uns am meisten
traumatisiert dass das niemand uns wollt
und wir dann eben nach dem haus dann und
und so lebten wir vier kinder zwei
eltern und die großmutter in einem
zimmer mit der tollen move und nichts zu
essen und ich finde dann betteln getan
habt nichts gekrankt waren die tür
geklopft und haben gesagt haben sich
etwas zu essen
das ist schrecklich das ist chören und
erinnerungsfähigkeit nicht überhaupt
noch gar nicht operiert doch viele seien
die zimmer sind automatisierte leute
aber ich weiß noch alles irgendwann ich
weiß nicht wann habe ich gemerkt dass
unser kühlschrank immer voll war
aber ich war nie in andere kühlschränke
wenn ich so sagen da hat das heißt er
später habe ich gemerkt bei uns ist es
immer voll bei anderen leute gibt es
drei kartoffeln und war es war ganz
anders
dass sie ein solches angst vor hunger
die idee ist geblieben nicht und du
hattest lange ein stück brot in dann in
eine tasche
der hunger und die schlimm flucht etwa
hinter sich aber die erlaubnis handy
ihres laber projekt jetzt für spätere
separat ihre heimat im jetzigen polen
und deutschland nummer zu besuchen
[Musik]
ich will eigentlich gerade ist erwarten
und gar nichts zu erhoffen
ich will das einfach noch mal sehen dass
es so
nachher kann ich den sternen nicht
übertreibe ich nicht gleich nicht wie
aber das ist so ein abschluss ammann
ende des lebens nicht ich muss mich dem
noch mal stellen
[Musik]
die flugzeit in deutschland wo sie oft
wahlkreis begleitet wird sie von einer
guten freundin natalia die 20 bischöfe
im pflegeheim geklärt du hast mir
erzählt dass hacker so großartig so
erinnere falsch und jetzt sage ich denke
ich mache es ist für mich ganz neue sie
haben hier mit so indischen zwar richtig
probiert koch die macht also was macht
sie gern einfach viel schmiede und das
braucht jetzt viel zeit nehmen freue
mich sehr
nicht mehr vor gericht müsse die
wenigsten alles tipptopp ich das gut
finden intensive wir haben kurz gut sei
dass sie vor schnitt über ihre lieblings
familie musik sind natalia hat sybille
immer unterstützt und dass sie zusammen
die in verbindung also wo mir ganz gut
aussieht immobilie adoptions unterlage
könnte bis über ihre lieblich familie
steht eventuell unterlagen und dann bin
ich auf lausanne konsequenten leiden
viel wie möglich nicht mehr vergesse
schon mal gesungen mal bissig womit sie
und was ich aber da ich ja
ja du sein schönster welt wenn sie früh
waren die oder sogar nur der welt finden
wenn es dann aber nicht so ist dann
denke ich das sicher einige von ihren
wurzeln in der vergangenheit vielleicht
bis fühlbare erkennbar werden und das
hilft da schon die motivation zu auf
indigo ist wirklicher frieden finden um
es mal mit finden und mini wurzel zu
entdecken
juni hervor sehnsucht und ganz recht
[Musik]
die flugroute dort gut zwölf stunden
zeit vor 20 jahren
natalia ist nun ihr so weit gereist
[Musik]
baugrund durch die drittgrößte stadt für
ihn offiziell lavita 15 millionen liegt
inoffiziell lebt von 30 millionen davon
in die wenige unterlagen wo sie ethisch
kalkutta als geburtsort des übergriffs
gerade eis und luft extrem führt
[Musik]
trotzdem reist bliebe die 2007 die
fremde heimat foto seiler möglichst
authentisch entdecken und schmeißt sich
das indische alltags lager
[Musik]
ist es auch ein user wird schnitt die
meisten klassen das in zwiebler
kalkutta zu der ernste steht vor der
wand rufe bewohner mit butler zum
überleben
[Musik]
schwimmen
ich glaube jetzt
[Musik]
du hast du nicht gesehen
ganz offensichtlich auch arm und sowieso
nur die wenigsten sehen wir dass verkehr
ziehen wir nicht
[Musik]
das ist nicht so dass sie froh dass ich
diese schweiz wohnen wählen in ihrem ex
mann ist die manchester auf der messe
haben wir die lappen
[Musik]
das ist städtli lütjenburg zu
norddeutschland dort verbrannt die
familie noch ein zweiter wahl krieges
nüssel ab angefangen zusammen mit sport
musik andere flüchtlinge
so was kleine stadt eben die einzige
sehenswürdigkeit noch ist das haus da
und dann haben wir es eigentlich gesehen
[Musik]
sportlich ewige mit roxy zertifikat
zwischen burg als flüchtlinge die sich
nicht willkommen gefühlt die familie
holz- nicht nur klassiker
[Musik]
es scheint als würde junge von damals
betriebe können sie mir ein stück
abschneiden nicht länger
und ich nehme alles mit ja ja ja aber
kein sie es mir ein zeichen dass marx
hat schon wieder eine dame entdeckt
menschen aber das war vor zwei wochen
das ist auch den hälfte ich nehme das
eine das andere nicht so ist
[Musik]
rot ist aber immer nur vertraut aber in
den strassen hiess es damals
was ist das auch ein schneller sie mit
dem buch was machen kannst du kannst
auch nicht erkennen
heiliges und kunstgewerbe und bioladen
[Gelächter]
aber noch nichts stand
bundesland schleswig-holstein noch im
regen so viele flüchtlinge besonders
dort wo sie zusammen mit ihrer familie
und andere flüchtlinge
das war jetzt das haus das und in dem
haus wohnt 28 leute und eben bevor wir
kam wohnte eine alte dame da drin
die häuser gab es noch nicht aber ich
weiß gerade ist jemand da jetzt rein
kommt guten tag
entschuldigen sie bitte darf ist etwas
fragen
ich bin barbara kroll geborene schuld
wir haben nach dem krieg in diesem haus
gewohnt beim ina peters und oben wohnt
die eben in pdfs nicht die vorerst ganze
haus hatte und dann musste die arme in
der dachkammer außen und die flüchtlinge
haben sich überall breit gemacht nicht
gerade ich hab und
sie hat das erlebte zu sehen ist und da
waren die toiletten drin nicht er war
keine toilette im haus und die war das
rollen die türen wurden überspült
ja ja ja genau und da waren auch schon
wach küssen da wollen wir zwei jahren
entfernt dürfen wir mal zur toilette da
einfach einfach dass ich in das eigens
gold zutage
das ist jetzt eben das waren die
toiletten nicht da musste man bei nacht
und nebel übern hof jetzt ist so das war
was man früher plumpsklos nannte nannte
das wurde zweimal im jahr ausgeleert
es stand bestialisch im sommer und im
winter war es gefroren und hier habe ich
sehr gelitten
meine schwester sind gestorben
wir waren nur unglücklich und hatten
hunger immer aber da das uns allen so
ging ich war kein einzelschicksal hsg
wildungen sogar und und wir haben das
einfach hingenommen wie können leute das
aushalten aber leute halten alles was
man arrangiert sich im unglück und wenn
so viele gibt die unglücklich sind dann
und dann ist das auch eine gemeinschaft
[Musik]
druck in indien am zweiten tag wenn
sarah und natalia computer designer ihre
lieblich familien finden sie wisse dass
sie mit 31 kinder ein hohes sich aber
nie klar ob sie ihre lieblichkeit
abgehängt oder ob sie aus straßenrand
gefunden hat
inspiriert dich
jetzt bestätigen wir nicht
zwar ist das trio irgendwo in der
jackentasche
[Musik]
tiflis
will sie kein die schreie seiner
übersetzerin abgemacht unterstützt
ich suche meine gute ja um das
kinderheim in dem ich damals war
hast du unterlagen ja habe ich gut also
wir sind hier in der long street nummer
vier ist soweit ich weiß jetzt hier das
historische haus
das ließ die gebäude mixed das genügt
[Musik]
den
was jetzt gesagt haben ich habe schon an
wasserrinnen limotive ich dir dass der
name der in meinem haus stehen
das wäre dann genau die täler und da
warst du auf dem balkon auch ja oder ich
war öfters daran die leute die kinder
oder vielen banken
die hatten die gelegenheit da zu uns
kommen und uns anzuschauen und damit das
heim einen guten eindruck machte und
umgebung sms bewegungsübungen übungen
machen und manchmal habe ich wirklich
keinen bock dazu datenhandel man von den
vor den gästen zu tun und da musste ich
als strafe auf dem balkon gehen nicht
wahr oft auf dem berg ja
daheim geht's nimmer da muss herr
zitronige
[Musik]
nicht hier wenn ich mal wieder sehr
langen turniers und das adaptive
warum
und ich habe das gebäude die einen
abstand und du musst kaufte und kaute
es ist ein schönes gefühl für mich ist
der 30 vergangenheit
mit den nerven
[Musik]
das gut ist schon ein großer teil von
sieben anfang vor dem label motto
mannschaft
[Musik]
denkt ihr
lütjenburg ad barbara hat ein
schwieriges jahr vor sich
und hier gleich ist ist das klappt dann
auch da sind die eltern begraben
die großeltern und christine und tod
ich mir doch nichts
papa ist sehr gut
[Musik]
christine und ute
das haben meine großeltern hätte
eigentlich paar blümchen kaufen soll
es war einfach so dass wir christine
zurücklassen mussten
die war krank und wir konnten sich auf
der flucht ich mitnehmen und wir haben
sie dann einfach im spital lassen müssen
weil ja sie ist dann sowieso gestorben
aber auf der flucht
wer sie da hatte man doch die hoffnung
dass sie vielleicht gerettet wird
nicht
ich bewunderte sich
[Musik]
ja klar
für barbara an diesem ort reismann vita
notiert vergangenheit wo sie praktisch
[Musik]
vom hinter heimweh kreis mit zehn
anderen ort gefunden damals in adaption
qualität so gleichzeitig auch als
kinderheim
53 indien sind die nummern immer
ziemlich
[Musik]
wir müssen
also wird doppel
die installierten
sozialismus das worden
[Musik]
die spur führt ins leere
irgendwo der riesige stadt versteckt
sich das alu in die vergangenheit
pflicht ist nur revision vielleicht aber
auch verwandte oder sogar ihre lieblings
mutter sarah rotman mieter suchen noch
jeden tag bis vertrauten der reform der
[Musik]
7 robert stadtwald wo ich damals in
deutschland
ich habe den ort wo ich eine glückliche
jugend verbracht habe und dann brutal
weg musste thun 70 jahre nicht gesehen
wahrscheinlich ist alles anders geworden
und die vielen zettel ist das viel
einfacher und chemie will dass sich die
neue freiheit fremden ort wo für ihn am
kopf suchen und weiß ich wen ihr herz
zahlung leipzig geboren und seit findet
zum teil gebraucht
ich werde bekomme eine reaktion dank und
der wird die geld verdienen
[Musik]
nächste woche wie nie fremd heimat ist
kolberg da wo sie oft war komisch vor
dem mord sie mit ihrer familie von
renesse flüchten
sehnsucht nach dem ort wo man geboren
ist und die kindheit verbracht ist jetzt
komme ich und es ist
und seiner erlaubt ihres heimatland
indien trotz rückschläge zuhri noch ihre
lieblicher familie nun durfte
im moment stelle
minute
apatow mit crepes
[Musik]